RICCARDO PELIZZI:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir, live
webinar from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
I'm Riccardo.
I'm the lead for GSuite
front and security.
ALBERTO ROJAS: I'm Alberto.
I'm a manager within
the [INAUDIBLE]..
RICCARDO PELIZZI: Today we're
going to dive deep into Gmail.
And we're going to talk
about how we protect users
against malware, ransomware,
spam, and phishing.
While we do the
presentation, you
can leave questions
in the platform
and at the end of
the presentation,
we're going to answer
a few of them live.
If we don't get to your
question, don't worry.
We will answer them
later in the platform.
So here's what's going to
happen in the next 30 minutes.
So first we're going to
talk about the major threat
vectors that are in scope
for this presentation.
We're going to present
several techniques
to address these threats.
And in particular,
we're going to see
how AI can help detection.
And finally, we are going
to put it all together
and see how all these
techniques are used effectively
to protect users.
And then, as I
said before, we're
going to have a short Q&A
where we answer your questions.
So here's the threat vectors.
We can see there are four
for this presentation.
The first one is spam.
Spam is just unsolicited
promotion messages.
We've all got a lot of them.
They are ubiquitous.
They're not a threat, per se.
But if they're
not kept in check,
if the number is
then it becomes a significant
drain on the user's time
and resources and so on.
I think recent
estimates put the damage
due to spam in only American
enterprises at about $20
billion per year.
Then there's
phishing, of course.
Phishing messages
impersonate legitimate email
communications.
And they trick the user into
giving out their credentials
to the attacker, to the phisher.
So most of them,
the one that you
might have also
gotten in your inbox,
they are large-scale campaigns.
So you would get an email says
that says, please click here
to reset your Paypal passwords.
These are sent to
millions of users.
But it's also important to talk
about spearphishing, especially
in the context of
the enterprise.
These are targeted attacks that
use information about the user,
about the victim,
to be more effective
and also evade a lot
of defenses based
on trends and large
numbers because they
affect a single user.
Then there is malware.
So malware is just a
malicious payload that
is delivered by various means.
They run with full privileges
on the user's machine.
So they can do pretty
much whatever they want.
Lately in the news
we've seen ransomware.
It's been very popular.
So this variant of malware
will encrypt your data
and then ask for a ransom
to decrypt your data
and get it back to you.
But more traditionally
malware is
being used to get a
foothold into organizations.
That's very common.
So this is called advanced
persistent threat.
Putting malware in one generic
user into the organization
is a good way of then expanding
your access in the organization
and staying undetected.
And then there are
client attacks.
So these are exploit
vulnerabilities
in clients and applications
and they execute
code on the victim's device.
And depending on the
type of vulnerability,
it could lead to the
same kind of infection
that you get from malware.
Now Alberto is going to describe
some techniques that we employ
to mitigate these threats.
ALBERTO ROJAS: Right, so yeah.
We've enumerated a few
of these attack vectors.
And well, we'll take a
quick tour of techniques
that we see these abuse actors
to deploy these attacks.
And consequently,
we'll talk about what
we do to detect them,
predict them, and make sure
that we minimize the effect
that they have on our users.
So he'll give you a glimpse
of what our team does,
why it's a hard problem,
and also maybe it
will give you some insights
into what to do to prevent.
There's a human
factor always present.
And one uses to be aware and
never let their guard off.
So we'll go through some
of these techniques, some
of these attack vectors.
Like I said, there's too many
of them to cover in these talk.
But we'll mention some of these.
And hopefully we will give
you an idea of what we see
and what we do.
All right.
So first thing, I want to
imagine that there were no spam
filters.
And there's someone
that's sending you
an email that you like.
So you do like it
the first time.
Don't think much of it.
But then you keep
a counter, right?
You receive it for a second
time, maybe a third time.
You notice that these
are all sent by someone,
let's call them Bob.
Well, what you might do,
if you have the ability
to write some rule,
would be to say
if the email's coming from
Bob, then let's mark it as red,
delete it, put them
in some other folder.
Well, that's more or less what
we do when people mark rules
as spam or we find out
through other means
that an email is bad.
We extract several
features from the email.
And we keep account
on how often we
see bad emails versus
good emails showing those.
You see here the screen
some examples of some
of those features.
The obvious ones
are the IP address,
the email address of the
sender, and then more aggregated
features like, well,
class C networks,
or domains, tildes,
stats like the length
of the message, words
that are mentioned,
colors, aspect
ratios, you name it.
And what we do is we
keep a counter keeping
a tally of how
often we see values
of those features
associated with badness.
Now, if you want to
take it a step further,
you can combine this.
Say an IP address is sort of
bad, you've seen a few of them.
Maybe 20% are bad.
It's hard to take and just put
them all in the spam folder.
So what we do is combine them.
Maybe you see partly
shady IP address,
but the domain is really bad.
Maybe those two combined
can be enough evidence
so that you can send an email,
actually, to the spam folder.
Now, an even more
powerful technique
is if you can combine
those features
before you do the aggregation.
So now you're tracking how two
specific values of a feature
together are related to badness.
So now we see what
value specifically
coming from one
ISP and containing
specific words, how
often those two together
are related to badness.
Now, if you're doing the
math, imagine you have, like,
1,000 of these features.
Pairwise combinations are
tuples of more than those.
You could clearly explode.
If you multiply that by
all the possible values,
it's no way we could
keep track of that.
So I guess part of
the secret sauce
that we have is figuring
out which of this to track
over time, how to evolve
them, and make sure
that we keep the set that
gives us the most return.
Now if the person who's sending
you this email is persistent,
they would probably be
aware that you blocked them.
And they will try to change
and go around your field.
Nowadays, it's
easy enough to just
get a new IP address, certainly
getting a new email address.
So what we want to
do is just make it
a little bit harder
for the abusers
to go around the protection.
So repetition is
great but we need
to figure out what aspects
are hard for the abusers
to go around, and which
ones they can just
circumvent easily.
So that prompts the question
of, what is it that--
for example, let's
focus on fishing--
what is inherent to fishing?
And it has to deceive someone.
It has to prompt them into
clicking on this link,
disclosing their
password information,
executing a file, and so on.
So one way to give
legitimacy to that is
to pretend to be someone else--
an authority, someone with
a lot of money, a business
partner of your organization,
depending on how much they
know about you.
And we see, like the example
you see on the screen,
someone might be pretending
to be Google tech support.
Now, if you just straight
out say Google tech support,
it's easy for us to catch that.
So we'll try to do
something that's
called spoofing, which means you
write some sentence, some word,
that can be interpreted
as something,
but literally doesn't say that.
So you can replace zeros for Os.
You can use what's called
Unicode homoglyphs, which
are characters that look exactly
the same that maybe characters
that you're used to seeing.
But they're not
the same character.
So any naive matching
algorithm would miss them.
So of course, we need
to be aware of those
and check for similarity.
We used canonicalization
of strings
to bring them back to a
form that can be compared.
And there's a whole
spectrum of sophistication.
So in the end of more
sophisticated attacks,
you can see even attacks
where the target a specific,
say, brand of smartphone,
where that phone makes
the two v's together look
like a w, but not in others.
Even though that narrows
down the spectrum of victims
that can fall for this,
it also makes our job
a little bit harder
because now you
have to pretend or try
to render these things
in different platforms.
So you can see how this thing
is not that easy to scale.
What they will
also do, of course,
is do the spoofing not only in
the display name that we'll use
sometimes, they will put an
email address in the display
name because you cannot easily
spoof the email address.
But if you put it in
your display name,
pretending that it is your
email address, you could do it.
Of course, we try
to detect that.
You could also put strings
prompting you to click on this
or to inherit this
sum of money--
though we can also detect,
so they to spoof that.
Now, things get
more sophisticated.
They move from
character-level spoofing
to images, which brings
us to the next topic.
One way to also,
again, give legitimacy
to this deceitful
message is to provide
the same visual
similarity or visual theme
of a legitimate email.
Now, you might just toss
a logo in there again.
Pixel by pixel, it's pretty
easy for us to catch.
But of course, it's also
easy for them to circumvent.
You just randomly change in some
pixels, maybe color distances
that are hard for
the eye to catch.
And then that force us to
make some more [INAUDIBLE]..
Then you can change the font.
You can do stuff to
trick the filters.
So we've been moving over
to machine intelligence--
so when we talk about
AI, we mention this--
to check whether a logo is
sufficiently similar to one
that we are trying to protect.
And even the layout,
the fonts, the placement
of the bottoms,
the overall colors.
Now just the fact
that something looks
like a legitimate one
from another brand
doesn't mean the email
is bad, of course.
So again, with the
feature repetition case
we combine these
things with others
so that we can relate
enough evidence
to decide whether an
email is good or bad.
Now about visual similarity,
we have to say this.
We even see cases where there is
no additional visual indication
or advanced logos.
Just with the text, they're
still able to trick some user.
If you're a domain
administrator,
nothing replaces a good
policy of keeping users aware
and constantly reminding
them to keep their guard up.
The last technique
we're going to cover
is about malicious attachments.
And just like any anti-virus
check, we do checks on files.
Because files can be used,
as Ricardo mentioned,
to create a bot net
and have your computer
join someone else
to launch attacks
against even other
organizations.
They can install software
to watch what you're doing,
either to get your credentials
or just for espionage.
And they can use ransomware.
So there's a whole
spectrum of bad stuff
that can happen once they get a
foothold into an organization's
computer.
Even if it's someone
not that consequential
in the organization
for financial purposes,
they can use that to
get to the person who
controls the accounts, to
the CEO, an information,
do social engineering and so on.
So we definitely
want to do all we
can to prevent these things from
ever being able to be executed.
So Gmail outright disallows
some types of attachments
from being present.
But the spammers have
other ways to do this.
They can take advantage of
traditionally non-executable
formats like documents.
We use PDF here as an
example, but there are others.
We can embed any binary object.
There's also more shady
ways of embedding,
like executing macros
requiring the user
to interact with the document in
some way to launch its macros.
It will even download
the content dynamically
so they can keep updating
this and changing it
so that the virus
signatures don't match.
So together with
advanced techniques
for extracting
these embeddings, we
need to apply techniques
for sandboxing
where we can
execute these things
in a restrictive environment.
And we can monitor
whether they're
trying to go home for a
command and control center
or trying to access your
files to encrypt them
in the case of
ransomware, and so on.
So Google has a range
of signatures that we
match against for regular AV.
But we do all sorts of
prediction and these sandboxing
techniques to also apply to new
cases that we've never seen.
We have the [INAUDIBLE]
which offers
configuration up [INAUDIBLE]
a domain administrator,
recommend you to keep in touch
with configuration options.
Familiarize yourself
with them and determine
what their level of
comfort it is according
to the tier of the
product that you have
and the risk aversion,
versus how much you
want to delay message because
you want to scan them.
We can [INAUDIBLE] to the inbox.
Now given the sheer
scale of email--
and frankly, the
sheer scale of spam,
which both range in
the billions per day,
and the time that this platform
or this medium of communication
has been around--
as you could probably
imagine, there's
a huge amount of
knowledge accumulated
over the years for
classification of spam
that would be very
hard for us to maintain
as a list of just rules.
Like, getting rid of the
old ones that are not useful
anymore, merging ones that
have almost the same--
it would be a pretty
daunting task.
So AI is a foundation that
lets us do several things.
One of them is serve as a
repository of knowledge that
is constantly being updated.
And things are not
relevant anymore get
taken out as part of
the training process.
Artificial intelligence,
and machine learning most
in particular, also
adapt over time.
New things, as long as
you see them in the field,
the systems will
learn to recognize it.
And thusly, depending on
the technique you use,
they also have the
capability to predict.
So you show them examples
you've never seen before.
They're supposed to
be used to catch them.
We want to exploit that.
And that's why we
keep continually
trying new methods that will
allow us to be more proactive.
So in general, AI enables
Google to, well, protect users
against abuse.
We also do recommendations
of all other cool stuff
with machine intelligence.
But in the case
of Gmail, we were
one of the early adopters
within the organization
to harness the power of AI.
But over the years,
we've built up
like a pretty good mix of
traditional proven techniques.
And we're sort of cutting
edge newer technologies.
We have a pretty significant
linear regression classifier
model because that's
what we started with
and we still keep it.
But over the time,
what we've come up with
is a multilayer,
multipipeline set up.
And by multilayer I mean take
a [INAUDIBLE] neural network
that use to recognize visual
features in something-- a logo,
or the presence of some
particular graphic element.
That in itself usually won't
be enough to classify something
as bad.
So again, one more feature
that we can extract,
VM machine learning to
determine, yes, there
there's a logo.
There's not a logo.
Then you combine that
with other features.
And you can feed that
into either manual rules
or, more likely,
to another model.
So we have multiple layers.
And we have parallel
pipelines in such a way
that even the final verdict we
can get from multiple master
models so we can put
them against each other,
make sure that we're getting
the best of both worlds.
You can get a second opinion
of sorts, if you will.
So the machine
intelligence landscape
is one that you have to keep
continually maintaining.
Now, it would be great if
this would maintain itself.
It's not so.
So our team needs to
keep continually adapting
the training of the models,
monitoring how well it's
detecting, what it's
supposed to be detecting,
and checking
against new attacks.
So some challenges that
we find is, well, it
starts with the training.
You sample specific instances
of both malicious emails
and good emails.
You need to teach the
system to recognize
both with the right
set of features.
You need to make sure that
they are labeled correctly.
You cannot take every
spam mark as face value.
You have to do some sort
of clean up and make sure
that those run reliably
and constantly.
You are able to train your
models with enough cadence--
be that every month
or week, every day,
or maybe continuous
learning models.
You have to get
into that cadence
to make sure that you're
constantly discarding
all information,
incorporate a new one,
keeping your model
tight and optimized.
Another aspect that
is particular to spam
is that not everyone
agrees what is spam.
What for some person
might be completely
undesirable for
some other might be
a mild annoyance, for some
other person might be just,
like, oh, useful
advertisement that they happen
to read every once in a while.
So it will be pretty hard for
us to keep a personalized, fully
fledged machine learning model
for every one of our users.
After all, these models
do take up space.
But luckily, you
don't have to do that.
There's a big section of
the email spectrum where
you can pretty much agree that
they're good, that they're bad.
We can keep the gray area
as a parametrized option
where you can feed it
with other signals.
You can tell your
model, OK, these
are the features coming
in from the email.
But these are also the
preferences of the user.
So you can adjust
your thresholds
and make the best decision
for each of our users.
Now, another challenge is
models will make mistakes.
You need to have a strategy
to deal with those mistakes,
to treat them
differently depending
on the type of mistake there
is, and to systematically
diminish them over time.
It is true that models,
like I said before, they
will adapt over time.
And they will predict
new situations.
But when they fail, typically
they don't recover instantly.
It will take time
for them to catch up.
That means we do have a rules
engine, blacklist, other maybe
less sophisticated techniques.
But you need those to
account for those gaps.
Now, we talked about errors.
Errors are not the same.
There's different
types of errors.
And there's different
problem spaces.
Take spam, for example.
If we miss a a spam email,
ends up in your inbox,
it's an annoyance.
You might not think that much
of it, and maybe delete it.
Hopefully you'll mark it
as spam and help us learn.
But maybe that's the end of it.
But on the other hand,
if we take a good email
and put it in the
spam folder, that
might make you miss something
important for your business.
It might make you miss
something important from someone
you know, and so on and so.
Clearly they're not the same.
For phishing, it's kind of
the opposite, but not quite.
Say if we send something
to the spam folder,
we think it was phishing
ans you miss it, yeah.
We already established
that is bad.
But if we really miss a phishing
email, put it in your inbox,
you execute that, the potential
for disaster is much bigger.
So there's really no good
or bad error in here.
There's still imbalance,
but both are bad.
So what we do in
that case is we try
to mitigate the effects of
these errors by having what
we can call softer hammers.
Like in the case
you're not completely
sure something is a phishing
email, instead of sending it
to the spam folder, we
can put some warnings
in place, some UI hints.
And Riccardo will
cover some of those
so that if you're a
domain administrator
you can keep your
users aware and always
on the lookout
for these signals.
How this all looks together--
like I said, over the years,
we have a pretty significant
linear classifier.
So of the 99.9% percent of
spammy and harmful email
that we detect,
about 9/10 of that
is already caught
by this classifier.
But of the remaining percentage,
but have a various heuristics,
that means this rule engine
that I was mentioning earlier
and the rest is with more
advanced machine learning
techniques.
Now, this is not
the full picture.
This is not, like,
disjoint sets.
There's a lot of overlap.
We try to maximize that overlap.
Actually, that's by design.
This is a concept
called defense in depth.
If you want to get
through our defenses,
you should always need to
break more than one thing so
that it's not easy
for you that you just
hit the jackpot and one
thing and then you're in.
So what we see here is
only additional coverage.
And we would like to
keep that small so
that there's no single
point where you can just
trick our defenses and get in.
That question mark you see there
is, of course, next generation.
We're always investigating
new techniques
that might be high or low
tech, that might involve
machine intelligence or not.
We're constantly
deriving new features,
pushing for new
standards that we
can use to protect the identity
or the integrity of emails,
and so on.
So that's a constantly
evolving field.
So next we'll go to see how
we perform the classification
and what it ends up
meaning to our users
and how can identify
what happened
within the
classification process.
RICCARDO PELIZZI: OK.
So Alberto's shown all
these powerful techniques--
AV scanning, how the
spam classifier works.
So how does Gmail
put it all together
to protect the users
against these threat vectors
that we presented before?
To explain that I think
it's easy to just go
through the flow of a
message from the sender
to the user, the end user.
And we're not talking
just about going
from the outbox of the sender
to the inbox of the user.
But we'll also consider how the
user interacts with the message
once it has been
delivered to the inbox.
OK.
So in particular, we
are interested in what
happens when the message
is malicious, of course,
because if our purpose is
to showcase the defenses,
hopefully nothing happens
if the message is benign.
And so we are going to see how
a malicious message flows--
you know, we're going
to see the lifecycle
of a malicious message.
And here are all the relevant
steps in more detail.
They are sorted
in temporal order.
So on the left,
you see delivery,
which is the first step.
And then all the
way to the right,
you see actions that are
taken by the user on the email
because you're soon
going from left to right.
Your eyes already opened
it and everything.
We are willing to go
through each one of them
in detail, of course, because
there are many [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
So note that something
is not shown in this flow
is that delivery and sync,
the first two phases,
happen on the server.
So they will be able to use all
the intelligence that Alberto
talked about.
All the other phases
happen on the client.
Also note how re-classification
is not quite defined
in a single place in the order.
That's because, by definition,
it can happen at any time.
Re-classification is the process
of rescanning old messages
with updated rules, updated
AV signatures and so on,
and making changing the
verdict of the classifier
and syncing the
information to the client.
So this can happen at
anytime, or not happen at all.
You can start this
off into any moment.
OK.
So here all the defenses that we
provided during the lifecycle.
So Alberto mentioned before
about the spam classifier,
the defense in depth.
This is another example
of defense in depth.
So as you can see, through flow
from all the way to the left
to all the way to
the right, you have
to go through a lot
of these defenses.
So there's multiple
layers here, too.
If you are overwhelmed with the
amount of red crosses and names
on the slide, that's
perfectly fine.
That actually was intended.
This slide is meant
to be overwhelming
because it gives me an
excuse to now go through
all the various
phases and explain
how all these defenses
affect the delivery
and an ongoing attack when
it comes to malicious email.
So the first phase is delivery.
This happens when we receive
the message in our main servers
but we haven't delivered
it to the user yet.
And in fact, we might
not deliver it at all.
So a lot of the spam messages--
or spam phishing, malware,
or whatever--
never makes the user's inbox
or even the spam folder.
So we don't just
decide whether we
send an email to the
inbox or the spam folder.
We can also reject
it altogether.
If you think you have a lot of
spam email in your spam folder
right now, imagine if
you had 10 times as much.
That's more or less, I
think, an approximate figure
about how much we
reject altogether
versus what we put in spam.
Note that most of our detection
capabilities are here.
As I mentioned before,
this is one of the phases
that happen on the server.
So this is where all of our
intelligence are available.
The later phases,
we basically use
metadata that has been generated
here and use it because now
when you're on
the client now you
can have user visible
effects besides rejecting.
The most common bit of
metadata, to give an example,
is, of course, the spam bit.
Is it spam or is it non-spam.
So does it go in the inbox,
does it go in the spam folder?
But there are other
pieces of meta-data
that we're going to show.
So the second phase is
sync, so again, we're
going to skip re-classification
because it doesn't actually
have an order.
The second phase is sync.
So this is when the servers
push the message to the client
so that then becomes
available to the user
and sees it in the thread listed
in the list of unread messages.
From a security standpoint, we
need to do to two main tasks
here.
So the first one is to propagate
all this security relevant
metadata that I
mentioned before.
So that will became my
client-side defenses.
The second main goal is to
sanitize untrusted content.
The main purpose here is
to sanitize the message
body, which of course, the
email protocol doesn't define
anything related to what
kind of malicious content
can appear in the body, how
much the HTML can be dynamic,
and so on.
So we do have a
very strict policy
about what can be served
on the user's device.
The idea is that the server
does the heavy lifting when
it comes to sanitization.
So the client gets
a piece of HTML
that is already safe to display.
And then we have message open.
So this is the phase that
happens when the user--
assuming the user selects
a message-- opens it.
And now you can
see its contents.
So this is a good place
for us to give visual cues
about security issues so we can
inform the user about something
that is maybe relevant, or warn
the user about something that
is definitely suspicious.
All these cues are
about those gray areas
that Alberto talked about.
If an email is
definitely malicious,
then it wouldn't get here.
But there's a long
trail of e-mails
that have some
suspicious behavior
or features that we can't
quite put in the spam folder.
So this will be where we start
warning the user from now on.
One example is, of course,
showing a warning button,
so that a banner that says,
look, this could be phishing.
These words were often
associated with phishing,
so be careful.
Another example of
a visual cue here
is an up-to-date virus check.
So we issue a virus
check, the same thing that
has been done during delivery.
We redo it when the
message is opened.
And the reason why we redo it
is because potentially the AV
has been updated with
signatures and the AV
could give a different verdict.
[INAUDIBLE] you're supposed
to take care of that.
So we do have eventual
consistency, eventually
the classification will do
it even when the user doesn't
open and push the update.
But the issue is that
re-classification
is a background job that
could take minutes to execute.
And the idea is we want to close
this window of vulnerability.
As soon as the AV
has a new signature,
it should have a visible
effect on the user's inbox.
So in that case, we
would warn the user
and prevent a download.
After the message
is open, the user
is going to interact with it.
And depending on
what type of threat
we talk about, if it's
phishing, malware, and so on,
we focus on different actions.
If your message is
carrying an exploit,
then the most relevant phase
is the download and attachment.
So let's go through a
scenario where the user sends
a malicious PDF that is supposed
to exploit an Adobe Reader
vulnerability.
So the first phase is that
maybe nothing happens at all
because, as you said
before, during delivery
we could reject the message.
So the user might
not see that at all.
The inbox is still empty
because the email was never
delivered to the user.
So let's assume, again,
defense in depth.
So let's assume that
one-layer phase.
The message gets through
because the signatures
were not up to date.
This is a very novel threat
that are AV's couldn't handle.
So the user then sees the
message and decides to open it.
So all is not lost.
So we have a few extra,
additional layers of defense.
For example, we have
not just a virus scan
but we also have a
lot of heuristics
regarding what is risky.
So if the attachment
is suspicious,
then we can at
least warn the user.
We don't have enough confidence
to reject the message
because we haven't matched
an exact virus simple,
but we can at least tell the
user that the attachment is
suspicious.
And for that, we can
use the warning banners.
As I mentioned before, even
if the attachment was not
malicious-- or at least was
not detected as malicious
by the virus when the
message was delivered--
it's possible that
it's because it
was due to an out of the virus
signature that eventually gets
updated because of course
we continually improves
our signatures.
And we also purchase updates
from anti-virus vendors.
So it's possible
that at some point
the antivirus will
change its mind.
So as I said before, we do
an AV check message open.
And that would prevent
you from opening the file.
As I said, the
reason is, of course,
because the re-classification
can take time.
And we want to reduce this
window of vulnerability.
So let's assume that
the exploit is also not
known when the user
opens the message.
So even the up-to-date virus
check doesn't detect anything.
So the user is not alerted
and falls into the trap
and opens the attachment.
Well, the user is still not
going to be compromised.
The reason for this is that
for a lot of very common file
types like PDF and
doc and so on, we
have an embedded preview.
This is just an HTML
preview of the content that
appears in the browser
window so that, of course,
it's not vulnerable
to PDF exploits.
So if you get
exploited finally--
which unfortunately
can happen-- is
that the user needs to also
download the attachment.
So let's go through
a different path
now than is usually taken
by a phishing email instead.
So in a phishing
email, you're probably
going to have some text that
entices the user into clicking
on a link, going on a
website and entering
their password because you
ask for the credentials.
This is probably going to be
looking like a common service
like Google.
And it will ask
for the passwords.
So let's go over
the scenario again.
So first thing is
that we are going
to assume that the previous
defenses have already failed.
Not because they are more
likely to fail for phishing-- so
we're talking about
rejecting a delivery
and showing all the various
message [INAUDIBLE]..
Not because you're
more likely to--
but just because for privacy.
We have defense in that.
We know how those work.
So let's move on to the phase
that is different for now.
So let's assume that the
message gets to the user inbox.
The user opens it and that
there is no warning related
to phishing through banners.
And therefore it clicks on
the link, like in this case.
Please click here to
reset your password.
Well, there are
two things that can
happen that will prevent
the user from actually
going to the site.
The first is that in those
gray areas where the back end
classifier has low confidence
about the reputation
of the link, we can at
least show a warning prompt.
This will hopefully
discourage the user
about proceeding to
the site, or at least
alert him that he needs to be
extra careful on this site.
And the second
thing is that we are
going to do an up-to-date
safe browsing check.
Now, the browser also has a--
Chrome, at least-- has a
safe browsing blacklist
synced on the client.
But the one using the
[INAUDIBLE] is more up to date
and more comprehensive.
The point is, again,
being more up to date
than the classification,
which also would detect this,
but that can take time.
And even if the
user gets no warning
and enters the
password, if the user
is taking proactive
steps then even
then the attacker account
is now compromised.
So for example, two
step verification
means that stealing
the password is not
enough to access the account.
We had a webinar, I
think, a month ago
regarding how to set it
up for your organization.
And-- oh, sorry.
And the other thing that we
also discussed last month
was password reset
extension, which
also needs to be set up for the
organization or for the user.
And it's very useful
because it will
reset the password immediately
if it's typed on another site.
Another type of phishing
attack is oAuth threat.
So this is the idea
that we are going
to phish for oAuth permissions
instead of credentials.
And it's effective
because users are
less wary of delegating access
or granting permission compared
to giving up credentials.
At least for enterprises,
we can block these attacks
by whitelisting which
applications can
ask for permission to the user.
And then the final scenario
that I want to go through
is business email compromise.
So this is very important
for enterprises.
And the idea of this attack
is that the phisher entices
the user to send confidential
information directly
to the attacker by
replying to the message,
so not by going
through our site,
but just by replying
to the email.
And let's go through
a scenario and see
how our defenses play with it.
So let's assume that the user
gets an email from a CEO.
This is an employee who receives
an email from the CEO and says,
please, it's urgent.
Please give us the detail.
Can you send them to us?
And so first thing is
that the user are not
so easy to fool
when they use Gmail
because most of
these attacks require
the sender to pretend to be
in the user's organization.
So one defense that is
super effective against this
is out of domain warning.
We warn the user that
this person is not
in the organization.
So obviously the
user will immediately
figure out that something
fishy is happening.
But let's assume,
again, defense in depth.
Let's assume that this fails.
So the user gets fooled
and he presses send.
The data is still
not going to be--
if the admin has
taken proactive steps,
the data is not going
to be leaked anyway.
We have this feature called
data loss prevention that
will run on outgoing
email and scan it
for sensitive information
such as social security number
and bank accounts.
So in this case, the
user is typing something.
And this is an IBAN, a European
Banking Account Identifier.
And if we have proper
VIP rules in place,
we can stop this message from
actually going to the phisher.
So to recap, we went
through these defenses.
Hopefully now that you've
seen them all one by one,
this slide is less daunting.
The main takeaway is,
again, defense in depth.
So many layers before
a user can be exploited
and can be attached.
And that's it for the talk.
So we are going to
be moving on to Q&A
now after a very short break,
I think, around a minute.
ALBERTO ROJAS:
OK, so we're back.
We have a few questions here.
And remember that if we didn't
go through your questions,
we'll go through them
offline on the platform.
So the first one is
what should users
be aware of regarding new
trends in phishing and malware?
Well, there's a growing trend
of going to actual malware.
As you get better at
detecting phishing attacks,
there's this ongoing
trend that we're
seeing of moving on
to malware attacks.
They're easier to hide.
It's hard for us to execute
every single malicious content
and attack every single
shady thing that it will do.
Like imagine
something that allows
you to click on some
elements of the UI.
We can only do so
much about that.
So it's a growing
threat, our detection
of content being
downloaded into the user's
computer and the
ability to execute
that in a safe
environment for us
to determine whether
it's harmful.
It's something we're
investing heavily on.
There's also, within
the fishing arena it's
moving on to more spearfishing.
Like, they will invest in
knowing a little bit more
about the target and
will try to convince them
with specific information.
Viral phish has been going down.
But the spearfishing--
it's less in numbers.
It's less prevalent in numbers.
But they're much more
damaging and much
more likely to succeed.
Like we've repeated
during this talk,
nothing replaces a
good awareness program.
And be constantly reminded
of this for the users
to never let their guard off.
So similar question, what are
specifically the best steps
to protect against
spear phishing?
Well, some of the things we
covered in the previous talk.
Strongly suggest you go
ahead and watch that.
But heed the warnings.
We try our best not make any of
our warnings a sort of cry wolf
so that they become
unconsciously bypassed
by a user.
So here we also need
the collaboration
of the main administrators
to make sure
that people heed those warnings.
Data loss prevention--
you need to configure
it to work correctly according
to the types of information
you want to prevent from getting
out of your organization.
We'll look at your
domain directory.
People are spoofing
the name of the CEO.
Keep those updated.
There's many things you can
do to improve the security
of your whole enterprise.
RICCARDO PELIZZI:
For this one, I
think the most
important one, even
though it takes some effort, is
set up two-step verification.
If you really care about
not getting spearfished,
definitely buy a
U2F security key.
They cost, what, $20?
You set it up.
Google supports it.
And that is, I think, the best
way of preventing spearfishing,
or at least preventing
the attacker
from accessing your account
when your password gets phished.
And if you're an enterprise,
then, the best thing to do
is buying all your
employees this key.
OK.
So the third question
is for mobile clients.
Are there protections
available there, as well?
Are all these
protection available?
Yes, most of them are.
So sometimes the
challenge, of course,
is how do you show these
cues in a reduced UI?
But most of-- for example,
the banners that we saw,
they are all available.
And I think all
the stuff that is
based on server side
functionality like DLP
or rejecting on delivery--
ALBERTO ROJAS: Absolutely.
RICCARDO PELIZZI: And
putting in the spam folder,
that's also all available.
I think of the ones that
we saw, the only two
that were not available were--
one was anti-virus
checking up to date.
But of course, on mobile viruses
delivered through attachments
are not as big of a threat
because you cannot just execute
an APK on Android, for example.
And most malware ends
up being for Windows.
And the other one was
preview because we
use the embedded previewer
on your mobile device.
For example, on Android we use--
I forget what it's called.
PDF reader.
But anyway, it's, of
course, on Android
the applications are
usually written in Java,
or at least some of the
parts are written in Java.
And they are more
resilient from exploits.
That's all, right?
OK, yeah.
That's all the questions.
So please tune in next Tuesday.
We're going to
have more webinars.
So I have the topics here.
So we have data analytics
and machine learning,
IT infrastructure, and
collaboration and productivity.
So thank you for watching
and see you guys next time.
ALBERTO ROJAS: Thanks.